[Music]
is the hijab 10
discount code for 10 discount on a wide
range of products including
premium ethiopian black seed products
how are you guys doing this is a video
which
i actually wanted to make because i had
a conversation with a friend of mine who
was pakistani
i am not familiar with the
country culture fully of pakistan i've
never visited it
and they've been there myself inshallah
one day i can go to that beautiful
country
one of the strong nations of islam
with one of the biggest populations of
muslims in the world
a beautiful country with fantastic food
and culture
but there are some things in the culture
which require challenging and this is
one thing
that um i came across i'm not saying
this is specific to pakistan i'm sure
it happens in other places but i came
across this video here
which you can see on the screen
which i found quite troubling let's take
a look at the video and let's have a
commentary on it
is
foreign
as you can see with this video this
man who is meant to be a peer and
this kind of religious figure surrounded
by women who are scarved
wearing hijabs and kind of feeding him
or serving him
and this man is naked um
i have no idea in what world they think
this is an appropriate kind of
interaction uh we in the east
sometimes you know excessively talk
about modesty
and the modesty of women and men and
dress code and so on
and now we have a man who's
naked absolutely naked
and who is being um served by these
women who are covered up fully um
and they're serving him you know
what kind of thing is this i mean isn't
this something that should be challenged
where are the religious figures
to challenge this behavior this is a
clear
you know violation of islamic modesty
and rules
and not just islamic modesty and rules
this is
something which wouldn't even be
tolerated here in the west
someone came and did that in the streets
uh we would be
he he would be ridiculed and maybe even
the police will be called on him so i
don't know why and how and what
paradigm this kind of behavior is
appropriate
um but once again when when you have the
mantle of being a religious peer
the haram becomes halal even though the
prophet muhammad
between that gray areas many people
don't know those gray areas
but this is not a gray area this is a
very clear haram
you are not allowed to show your private
parts to
the opposite gender so
why on earth is this man who is a fake
uh religious figure a fraudster
or either that or an ignorant man why is
he
um sitting there and all these women
he's sitting there naked and all these
women are coming to him
what kind of thing is this it's
absolutely disgusting and despicable
thing
which the religious authorities in that
country
should be making very clear the second
video i wanted to show you is
something even more atrocious
let's take a look at what's happening
[Music]
here
as you can see in this video you have
people coming over
and prostrating to this
religious figure this religious fraud
and this religious fraud who's accepting
all these prostrations from people
you know is clearly um
misguided is ignorant and so are the
followers
of of this fraud who are also ignorant
they don't know what they're doing
because prostration belongs to allah
alone and in fact there are hadith to
that effect my other benjamin
one time he came to the prophet muhammad
and
he wanted to prostrate to him okay
who is one of the sahaba he wanted to
prostrate to him because he saw the
you know archbishops and the patriarchs
of other nations doing the same to their
leaders and the prophet explicitly
forbade him
from doing so so with such clear-cut and
decisive evidence from the sunnah itself
even an argument that says well you know
joseph yusuf alaihissalam
his parents prostrated to him so what is
the
what is the man now what is the
objection
would not be able to be made because
or the sharia of those who came before
us
is not um it does not stand when there
is a clear abrogation
in the sharia of islam as sent by the
prophet muhammad as we can see
with this as we know now with this
hadith therefore
in summation i would say that these
practices
need to be filtered through the lens of
the quran and sunnah
especially because they not only relate
to
jewish prudential issues philo type
issues
but they do also relate to creedal type
issues belief type issues
it's very important that when we want to
worship allah
we do so with basira with insight
and we do so with proper practice
as per the quran and sunnah and that is
all i wanted to say to you
so just for watching this video
one thing i would say is it's important
to arm yourself
with knowledge and start basic start
with the five pillars of islam
and the five pillars or six pillars of
iman
and then branch out from there was
allah
you